[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
do you work here
the master class video from your
instagram yeah
uh hold on let me bring that up
did you not pull that no god jesus
christ man you didn't say
why wouldn't you just pull that
automatically
tom i don't live in your brain man i
don't know what you're thinking what is
going on with you in the doctor oh we're
gonna work it out believe me
what's going on
nothing
nothing you want to kill him last week
your mom's house posted on instagram
that they're currently hiring right now
summer interns social media people post
production people video editors i was so
excited i'm throwing my hat in the ring
i think it's a long shot but you know
you see that opportunity you gotta at
least try for it so we're gonna go
through this video is gonna be applying
to your mom's house go through the
application go through the requirements
and while you're watching this if you if
you're like oh i meet all these
requirements i would love to do this
dude go apply it would be so sick if
someone got a job at ymh from watching
this video nothing would make me happier
than that
except for if i got it but we'll see
what the requirements are we're going to
go through this video is applying to
your mom's house all right so the
initial post said we're hiring editors
production interns social media interns
and post-production interns swipe to see
if you meet the qualifications
um so let's go with full-time editor
first i feel like that would be the
biggest like
hiring like that would be sick to be
there full time so they're looking for
editors to join their ymh post
production team must have experience
with adobe suite
[ __ ]
all right so the requirements are off to
a rough start i use imovie to edit
that's just what i grew up using to edit
stuff but i i get the basis of
video editing i feel like i could easily
start training and practicing in adobe
suite to by the time that you know i
really got in from someone for an
interview or i had to edit something i
would be just as proficient and adobe
sweet as i am now in imovie and i would
call myself pretty proficient in imovie
even tom and christina themselves have
complimented my editing using imovie so
uploaded to youtube at
joke world
that's who did it
um and the world is w-r-l-d
he cut this for over like four minutes i
love it and he really overlapped your
reactions to like yeah yeah it's so good
yeah these it always amazes me because
the amount of time it must take to do
this
right this is like a real understanding
it's like those phony phone calls we get
yeah you're like how the [ __ ]
it takes hours huh that clip's got to be
hard to argue if anyone's watching this
video as the application that's got to
carry a little bit away i know that i
technically don't meet the adobe suite
requirement but i will practice i will
learn it and look they like it they like
what i can do
come on just give me the job all right
what's the next requirement must be
local to austin [ __ ]
okay this is going not that good so far
but
okay maybe i'll do
yeah that's not good
i'm not local to austin um
here's the here's something summer
intern i'll live in austin for the
summer
let's get okay we're done with the
full-time editing full-time editor if
you met those requirements if you live
in austin and use adobe suite uh go
apply to the full-time editing job and
we're moving on to the interns here at
joke world we only want to be interns
anyway that would i would hate to be a
full-time actor
at your mom's house all right let's see
what the intern requirements are
i just feel like i am more of an intern
kind of guy anyway
studio jeans is looking for summer
interns production internship social
media internship post-production
internship
must be local to austin
no exceptions
i get that it says no exceptions but how
much does an airbnb for the summer in
austin airbnb
austin
um all right
i'm one adult
my check-in date will be
let's put it for
june 5th
and my checkout date will be how long is
the summer we'll do
august 5th in two months
but i'm willing to go longer let's just
see how much this would be
um
okay
yeah it's like if i get a shittier place
it could be fine
1500 a month it would be more it would
it would be it'd be a rent increase from
my apartment but i'd also be getting
paid to be the intern which is so that's
fine so i'm totally willing to live in
austin for the summer let's pre i'm
local to austin local austin for the
summer check got that done i will easily
pay
four thousand dollars this summer
and airbnb fees and just try to break
even with being the intern i feel like
what the knowledge and experience and
industry uh behind the scenes [ __ ] that
i would gain from being a ymh intern
would be well worth breaking even in the
money aspect so
or even losing money losing a few
hundred dollars after what this would
make me versus what i would spend on an
airbnb
totally fair trade-off i'm more than
willing to lose money on this venture so
consider me local to austin i'm the most
awesome local dude that you'll ever meet
i'm an austin local in fact
i'm so local to austin i'm doing the
rest of the video with this hat on that
way i passed optics test oh there's no
way that dude doesn't live in austin
look at that hat okay what's next
um the intern option has so many more
options of what you can do to like
they're looking for production
internships social media interns and
post-production interns so maybe the
adobe suite thing wouldn't even matter
if i was like a social media intern you
know and i definitely can do a great job
running
your social media i mean like half of
what joe crawl is is branding and
thumbnails and and different logos and
stuff like that that can get eyes on
comedy and on comedians videos you know
so
the other thing about the adobe suite
thing is in my case specifically is like
yeah i don't use that specific editing
thing editing software but i've used
your mom's house video and been able to
re-edit that in imovie to amass millions
of views with it
and that's just a fact like if you look
at some of the tom sagor themed videos
on joke world's page i mean
this one
uh tom scores on the thumbnail of and
he's in majority of this reaction to
will smith video 3.1 million views that
would be tied for the third most viewed
page on all of your mom's house you keep
going down there's another one with tom
segura in it at one million another one
with a million another one with a
million these are normal ymh numbers
like that's like an episode of two bears
is getting similar views to what i'm you
know doing with tom segura content
editing up in creative ways and then
redistributing it so people can enjoy it
in a new way with a new twist
this is this is proof i guess my proof
is this channel i can get millions and
millions of views
the same amount almost as though your
mom's house
page
with your mom's house content so my
editing is there i don't think that
there should be any question about
editing or being able to attract people
into social media at this point my
resume is really just pitching you guys
in this video um so
intern i'm going for social media intern
and i'm taking this hat off as a social
media intern i'd obviously fulfill the
job requirements do all my tasks on time
work very hard but i think i have some
other things to offer in the meantime
and some down time that could really
help the ymh brand i know they're super
you know they're expanding right now
very fast they just added the danny
brown show they're one of the best
production companies in the world one of
the best channels on youtube so they
definitely don't need my help but i just
think it could be cool like how barstool
has schooly scenes on youtube how
crystalia has like a lifestyle vlog
behind the scenes thing like life with
chris or more chris um
that kind of thing i think doing that
with ymh could be so sick because
there's so many great characters and
comedians and like just people that that
the fans care about so much like the
studio boys obviously tom and christina
and bird dr drew danny brown whatever
you want like just uh behind the scenes
call it gene scenes behind the scenes
like lifestyle vlog of just like people
showing up to work you know like handing
out coffees or like the guest gets there
what happens right after the episode is
cut episodes over he takes off his
headphones and there's a few
pleasantries or some more dialogue that
we miss or like what happens when they
show up or just like people interacting
completely normally completely
authentically and the stuff that gets
put on camera is hilarious and great and
amazing but i think right now like
what's really popping off is authentic
behind the scenes stuff that that people
just get to see how how it really is to
be tom segura and show up to do two
bears or how it really is to be working
in the booth and you're in a dive and or
like just like
footage just footage footage plays
people love it and i think i could do a
really good job with gene scenes i think
it'd be cool to post gene scenes on my
channel joke world that's so many die
hard comedians or comedy fans it's
rapidly growing and it's it's a
different audience obviously your mom's
house is a way larger audience and it's
people that just love your mom's house
so it could
do super well on that channel too but it
could be something different about
you know this this smaller channel
granted it's 90 000 people that all know
who
these characters are at your mom's house
and see this kind of behind the scenes
vlog put together by some other youtuber
or this intern which would be me and
it would just be different it would be
something that not a lot of people are
doing i love how barstool does it
crystalia is having a lot of success
with it and the word gene scenes is like
so money like that you gotta use that
steal this idea from me if you want well
don't don't don't just hire me let me do
it dude let me do gene scenes along with
the real intern work i'm not just asking
to do something that you didn't ask for
in the requirements or that you didn't
post a job for i know you didn't say
does anyone have a cool idea about a
vlog that we could do we're hiring for
that now i know that you're like dude
we're just hiring editors we're just
hiring social media people
i get that i just think that this would
be a super sick idea because your mom's
house has these so many different
characters that everyone would just eat
up gene scenes million dollar idea
literally could be a million dollar idea
like
and i'm not i'm i'm not on i'm filming
this dude i'm not asking for any like
attention or anything like that i just i
just want to film
everyone at ymh acting normal and cut it
up and i think people would really
really enjoy that once a week once a
week jean scenes think about it
think about it dude
hire me hire me so what do you guys
think i think it'd be so sick to work
for ymh and obviously i've been editing
comedy videos for a long time i know a
lot about the industry i know what plays
on youtube i know how to get views i
know how to make thumbnails i know how
to do this so although i don't mean
every requirement exactly
just hear me out and uh yeah i just
think it'd be cool i think i'd learned
so much about the industry so much
valuable knowledge from this and if you
guys think that this could be a good fit
for me maybe start a little bit of a
grassroots movement dude maybe we start
hitting up the ymh instagram and being
like consider at joke world consider at
joke world
or maybe that's super annoying and they
would be like we were considering that
until a bunch of people just ruined our
comment section so maybe use discretion
if you think that i could be a good fit
for this
and and you want to you know
poke at him a little bit if you've been
really moved by this video then go for
it and if you're like this was one of
the stupidest videos i've ever seen then
keep that to yourself either way we can
all agree that gene scenes would be
super dope and that they should do that
idea even if they don't hire me but then
also we should agree that we should all
be mad if they stole my idea because
this video will be on the internet
forever but still we can all agree that
we wish that existed right
am i wrong about jean scenes
who would not watch that once a week
behind the scenes vlog of your mom's
house of all of our favorite guys come
on gene scenes consider it but only with
me i guess i'm just going to email them
the link to this video with the job
social media intern in the title
and then they're going to be like what
the [ __ ] is this dude this is the worst
application ever you just proved that
you don't meet any of the requirements
so then you start talking about your own
ideas that aren't even listed on here as
things that we're looking for but
crazier things have happened dude could
you imagine
if this video got me hired all i want to
do is work there for the summer dude
consider it thank you for watching make
sure you subscribe to joke world to stay
in the comedy loop the first ever media
brand dedicated solely to the world of
stand up comedy keeping you guys up to
date with everything going on with your
favorite comedians your favorite podcast
your favorite stand up all that's good
stuff it's joke world it's the place to
be unless i work for ymh then ymh is so
much better than joke world but right
now joke world to the moon we're taking
it over um i don't know how to end these
videos i never do so just follow us on
instagram
hit up ymh say hey joke roll did you
know jake you do a really good job and
i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you